prenons quelques minutes pour faire le
point avec le docteur car le vice
président de l'association des médecins
microbiologiste du québec pour soir dr
weiss on vient d'entendre monsieur
legault et messieurs aroud docteur
arruda directeur
attendez vous à ce que ça augmente
l'école on va pas disparaître en trois
jours je vous montre la carte du canada
on est maintenant à neuf morts au canada
94 qu'au québec on le dit 186 en
colombie-britannique 221 en ontario donc
monsieur vice quand le premier midi
attendez vous à ce que ce combat-là dur
l'on va gagner ultima mais ça va durer
longtemps
on prépare les gens des mauvaises
nouvelles ou si la wii bien sûr c'est
comme à la guerre alors il faut savoir
le temps travaille pour nous parce
qu'éventuellement on va finir par avoir
avoir des médicaments et un vaccin ou
des vaccins avec le temps donc on va
gagner en mousseline mais c'est sûr
qu'il va y avoir des obstacles à
franchir
c'est sûr qu'il y aura des moments
difficiles et c'est pour ça qu'il va
falloir s'armer de patience ne pas se
décourager
c'est pas quelque chose qui va se régler
du jour au lendemain les gens qui
veulent une solution facile et rapide ça
n'arrivera pas et c'est normal il faut
avoir une certaine résilience par
rapport à tout ça docteur vincent
on parle beaucoup des tests on souligne
l'importance de tester la population
expliquez-nous comment ça fonctionne
ce test qu'ovide 19 alors la façon dont
ça fonctionne c'est qu'on doit vous
prendre un aiguillon et on doit le
mettre dans votre nez qui allait en
arrière dans votre pharynx il faut
frotter le pharynx il faut avoir des
cellules et après ça on va essayer aussi
de faire un même la même culture mais au
niveau de votre gorge ont vingt médecins
dans un milieu de transport donc un
petit tube et on en voit ça au
laboratoire de santé publique est depuis
maintenant quelques heures qui sont ces
gars synthèse hôpitaux comme le mien
l'hôpital général juif mais aussi le
cuse hume et de ce qu'ils ont commencé à
faire les tests localement donc on en
voit ça dans les laboratoires de ces
hôpitaux là il va y avoir sept plutôt au
québec qui dans une première
ils vont faire des tests et là on met ça
sur une machine on va aller chercher le
matériel génétique du virus
c'est une technique qu'il ya entente
elle prend environ trois heures ni à
prétendre sortir oui ou non si vous êtes
positif au négatif alors c'est comme ça
qu'on fait grosso modo mais est-ce qu'on
va arriver avec une efficacité
comparable à celle par exemple des
coréens qui arrivait à faire tester
injustement quelques-uns m'a donné les
résultats ou des individus en quelques
heures
je suis pas sûr que de trop ce qui s'est
passé en corée il ya beaucoup
d'informations qui ferait de corée c'est
un petit peu opaque
alors n'y a pas eu beaucoup de
publications qui sont venus non plus
deux corées des tests en quelques heures
la technique pendant quelques heures
mais la capacité de le faire peut
prendre beaucoup plus de temps donc mais
vous savez au québec on augmente
tranquillement notre capacité de faire
des tests comparé à souhaiter t il ya
deux semaines
aujourd'hui on est capable d'en faire
beaucoup plus sous question pas avant
qu'on l'obtienne si vous voulez un
certain rythme de croisière la capacité
et la capacité d'en faire et on va
découvrir forcément d'autres cas donc
les nombres dont on parlait tout à
l'heure
vont augmenter je vais à la question 2
tout de suite leur en gagnant vous
demande gagnant vous demande quel
pourcentage on voulait déjà demandé mais
faut répéter
quel pourcentage des patients testés
positifs doivent être hospitalisés
qu'elle soit reçoivent style mais c'est
très variable
ce qu'on va dire c'est que grosso modo
on peut dire peut-être à peu près 10%
mais si vous regardez les données en
base de 50 ans et moins de 3% en bas de
40 ans et encore moins
mettez vous montez un autre poids temps
ça devient un chiffre beaucoup plus
important soixante dix ans et c'est donc
on peut dire 10% mais vous savez si vous
avez envie de 40 ans ça va être en bad
important et qui vous avez en othe
soixante dix ans ça va être au delà 30%
donc ça varie beaucoup selon le groupe
d'âge très bien isabelle gamma je vous
demande combien de temps avant que le
comédien
diminue ça revient beaucoup
reviendra-t-il à chaque année comme la
grippe la toute première journée je vous
avais posé cette question
oui alors réponse à la question numéro 1
combien temps qu'un m'a dit monsieur
legault il faut être résident patient et
attendre une guerre continue c'est un
marathon
donc si vous regardez des modèles en
parle de certainement plusieurs semaines
voire plusieurs mois
c'est difficile de donner à cette
étape-ci une durée au québec on a pris
des mesures très extraordinaire très
rapide efficacement à un moment où le
nombre de cas était encore faible et au
moment où on a fermé les frontières
donc on a peut-être une chance au québec
d'enrayer si vous voulez les ennemis
qu'on a vu dans d'autres pays
alors je pense que le travail de tout le
monde va vraiment être de se mettre
ensemble et de travailler de façon
coordonnée de ram et tout le monde dans
le même
dans le même temps elle que ça va
revenir dans le futur c'est possible il
ya des rues des coronavirus pas
dangereux y aura 4 donne des rues mais
dont la tout le temps on verra bien
beaucoup de questions sur l'état des
recherches pour un vaccin normes en bois
vous demande quel est l'état des
recherches mondiale pour un vaccin et
vous avez dit tout à l'heure on va
éventuellement trouver un vaccin est ce
qu'on s'entend pour dire les experts
comme vous que ça prendra quand même au
moins à bien écouter quand on met un
vaccin sûr marche il faut deux choses il
faut qu'ils soient sécuritaires et
efficaces pour prouver et qui fonctionne
et il faut aussi prouvé que quand on
voulait être ministre il n'y a pas une
catastrophe
donc il ya un certain temps qu'il va
falloir avoir poussé ces vaccins ceci
étant dit a déjà aux etats-unis une
étude de prendre à elle de phase 1 à ses
débuts début embryonnaires sur a déjà un
vaccin alors on n'a jamais vu dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
je pense que favre est important de le
rappeler un moment donné quelque chose
pendant 2 3 mois un nouveau virus
apparaît créer une pandémie pareil mais
il ya déjà été identifiés sur lequel on
travaille avec un vaccin
vous savez on fait beaucoup de
parallèles avec la pandémie de 1917 1918
j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion un jour
d'en parler de façon beaucoup plus
précise et exhaustive mais t'as pas
grand chose à voir on est dans deux
mondes différents
il ya des défis aujourd'hui n'avait pas
en 1917 mais quand il ya eu la pandémie
de la grippe espagnole en 1917
les gens doivent comprendre que le virus
de l'influenza cette époque là n'avait
même pas été isolé donc ceux qui avaient
pris du temps mais vous m'amenez une
autre question parce qu'on fait des
parallèles vous avez raison de le dire
et on dit par exemple qu'en 1917 18
il ya eu un premier cours au printemps
comme actuellement il ya eu un répit
durant l'été et la grippe espagnole est
revenue encore plus forte à l'automne
est ce que c'est un scénario qui
pourrait se reproduire
alors écoutez on est dans deux scénarios
complètement différent on peut pas
comparer les deux états 1917 c'est la
première guerre mondiale les gens sont
dépendants des tranchées l'europe est
déchiré il ya une révolution en russie
les conditions socio sanitaires ne sont
pas les mêmes
on a pas de vaccin y'a pas de
médicaments on vit dans un monde
complètement différent de ces 1917 on
n'est pas vraiment avec les mêmes défis
on a par contre d'autres défis on a
beaucoup plus de voyages on à l'avion ne
s'est pas vraiment mis en tête et on a
aujourd'hui la capacité de faire des
vaccins de détecter les virus de tête et
les jambes pour imaginer aussi en 1917
on n'était même pas capable d'aller
tester ces gens là pour savoir s'il
avait ou pas le virus
c'était un diagnostic présenti cluny
donc on n'est vraiment pas du tout dans
la même dimension
et dans la même dynamique très bien je
vous ai déjà posé la question je suis
désolé dr weiss mais on est obligé de
répéter et salons manière beaucoup
beaucoup de questions les gens le
demandent comment faire pour renforcer
son système immunitaire
les probiotiques la vitamine c des zincs
peuvent-ils peuvent-ils protégé du
virus écoutez il n'y a pas de recette
miracle pour renforcer votre système
immunitaire tout sa prothèse n'y a rien
qui a été prouvée est à ne va rien vous
s'en va pas vous protéger contre le
virus
la seule chance c'est qu'on sait que si
vous avez de saines habitudes de vie
ça va certainement vous gardez dans un
état de stress moindre et on s'est
parfois on peut le strait un sens un
effet négatif sur votre ministère donc
c'est sûr que si vous avez des habitudes
de vie saines ou vous hydrater bien vous
ne fumez pas vous allez dehors marché
une pas de l'exercice et cetera un
enfant de facteurs qui vont vous donner
beaucoup plus que des parts et de
l'argent dans toutes sortes de produits
dont l'efficacité est totalement inconnu
et qui peuvent parfois même être
problématique très bien d'observer je
vous lance une dernière question avant
de vous laisser pour la prochaine est ce
qu est ce qui vous étonne le plus
face à ce nouveau virus qu'est-ce qui
vous vous y êtes vous là le spécialiste
le plus ce qui m'étonne le plus
finalement c'est dans le bon côté des
choses c'est la résignation de la
population à vouloir suivre les
consignes qu'on en consomme
écoutez on a le québec le monde a changé
dans les trois dernières semaines
on vit dans un monde qui n'était pas
celui d'il ya trois semaines et c'est
probablement le plus grand défi pour
certainement pour les médecins
certainement pour la population pour un
talent immense majorité d'enfants dr
weiss merci on se retrouve avec un bon
travail